[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien sur Public Sénat
on est ensemble tous les jours du lundi
au jeudi à 18h et 22h pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos experts
et voici le sommaire de ce 24 janvier
l'IVG n'est pas menacé en France et la
Constitution n'est pas un catalogue de
droits sociaux et sociétaux en se
prononçant à titre personnel contre la
constitutionnalisation de l'avortement
le président du Sénat Gérard Larcher
relance un débat qui semblait consensuel
faut-il protéger l'IVG d'une
hypothétique offensive d'un pouvoir
populiste les exemples américains ou
polonais justifie-t-il cette réforme
constitutionnelle débat dans une minute
qui va tourner notamment autour des mots
liberté garantie vous verrez et puis
pour notre second thème c'est un droit
de suite que je vous propose 3 semaines
après les cru qui ont frappé le Pas de
Calais dans des communes déjà inondées
début 8 novembre va continuer à
intensifier nos efforts pour pomper et
pour évacuer cette eau de évidemment on
sera à leur côté pour restaurer au plus
vite et puis on sera à leur côté aussi
pour
indemniser comment l'État vient-il en
aide aux habitants le modèle économique
des assureurs est-il remise en cause par
ces catastrophes à répétition faut-il
raser certains quartiers inondables et
si oui comment ne pas ruiner celles et
ceux qui vivent réponse dans trois qu4
d'heure mais d'abord cette question qui
divise le Sénat faut-il inscrire l'IVG
dans la Constitution Samia de chir il y
a peu de doute sur l'issue du débat
ouvert cet après-midi à l'Assemblée
nationale les députés devraient
approuver l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution une idée beaucoup moins
consensuelle au Sénat hier Gérard
Larcher s'y est publiquement opposé si
l'IVG était menacé croyez-moi je je me
battrai pour qu'il soit maintenu mais je
pense que la Constitution n'est pas un
catalogue de droits sociaux et sociétaux
une position partagée par le président
du groupe centriste Hervé Marseille mais
sur les sujets sociétaux les
parlementaires sont libres de leurs vote
plusieurs sénateurs de droite et du
centre sont favorables à l'inscription
de l'IVG dans la Constitution et ont
déjà annoncé qu'il voteraiit pour comme
la centriste anque billon alors pour moi
ce n'est pas un droit anecdotique c'est
un droit fondamental pour les femmes il
mérite d'être sanctuarisé pour ma part
j'ai toujours voté pour donc je
renouvellerai ce vote pour en réalité le
Sénat a déjà voté en faveur d'une
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG c'était
en février dernier à 166 voix pour
contre 152 la chambre haute avait adopté
une proposition de loi du groupe
insoumis amendé par le sénateur de
droite Philippe B plutôt que d'inscrire
un droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution il proposait le terme de
liberté de la femme de mettre fin à sa
grossesse une dont s largement inspiré
le gouvernement qui propose à son tour
une liberté garantie à la femme d'avoir
recours à l'IVG la proposition est jugée
acceptable par la gauche sénatoriale qui
votera pour c'est moins ambitieux que ce
que je rêverais de mettre dans la
Constitution c'est évident maintenant
pour moi il y a une chose qui est claire
et qui est claire depuis le début le
meilleur texte c'est le texte le plus
ambitieux possible qui peut passer un
texte plus ambitieux qui ne peut pas
passer il est très joli il est voilà
tout beau tout ça mais il n'est pas
utile parce qu'il peut pas passer si le
résultat s'annonce serré la gauche se
veut confiante les élections
sénatoriales de septembre lui ont fait
gagner six sièges tandis que les
républicains en ont perdu 12 de quoi
déterminer un vote qui se jouera sans
doute à quelques voix
près le Sénat va-t-il voter contre
l'insccription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution on en débat avec agnè
caniller bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénatrice rattachée au groupe LR
rapporteur de la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à protéger et à
garantir le droit fondamental à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
qui avait été déposé en octobre 2022
Anne Cécile mafer bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes présidente et cofondatrice de
la Fondation des femmes j'accueille
également lauriline fontaine bonsoir et
bienvenue professeur de droit public et
constitutionnel à l'Université Paris
sort bonne nouvelle et vous publiez la
Constitution maltraité anatomie du
Conseil constitutionnel c'est aux
éditions Amsterdam Matthieu bonsoir
Mathieu élitorialiste politique je
reprends une partie des des mots
prononcés par par le président du Sénat
la Constitution n'est pas un catalogue
de droits sociaux et sociétaux c'est en
ces termes à titre personnel entre
autres hein il y a eu d'autres phrases
euh que Gérard Larcher explique son
refus de constitutionnaliser l'IVG agnè
can est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
lui écoutez déjà Gérard Larcher a énoncé
que c'était une position personnelle
parce que sur les questions de société
euh au Sénat nous sommes chacun libre de
nos votes c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui je suis bien dans la
capacité de vous dire ce qui va se
passer le 28 février prochain au sein de
notre hémicycle néanmoins la position du
président elle est constante euh il est
il avait déjà fait part de cette
opposition et nous l'avions voté en
octobre 2022 il elle avait été réitérée
en février dernier 2023 et aujourd'hui
il réaffirme cette même position donc il
y a une constance dans la confirmation
la mienne c'est que moi je considère que
ça ne changera pas grand-chose de
l'inscrire dans la Constitution en fait
le problème c'est véritablement la
l'effectivité du recours au droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et il faut pas se tromper de débat c'est
pas un débat si sommes-nous pour ou
contre l'IVG bien sûr mais bien
sommes-nous pour ou contre la
constitutionnalisation d'IVG ce qui
n'est absolument pas la même chose on y
reviendra sur les moyens effectif le
centre le nombre de centrg dans ce pays
le fait que il y en a de de moins en
moins ce sera une partie de de de notre
débat mais évidemment le le la le
l'essentiel de de cette première
émission porte sur cette
constitutionnalisation Gérard arch il
affirme également que l'IVG n'est pas
menacé en France un Cécile mafer est-ce
que c'est vrai tout simplement
aujourd'hui alors c'est vrai et c'est
pas vrai ça dépend ce qu'on appelle des
des menaces sur l'IVG c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les personnes et les
mouvements qui sont contre l'avortement
ne sont pas en position de décider ne
sont pas en position aujourd'hui de
changer la loi donc à dans ce sens-l on
peut dire qu'il est pas menacé mais nous
on a on vient justement de faire un
rapport à la fondation des femmes qui
essae de de suivre un petit peu les
mouvances ces mouvances là et la manière
dont elles sont en train d'influer sur
les réseaux sociaux et dont elles
cibleent tout particulièrement les
jeunes les 13 17 ans sur les réseaux
sociaux et c'est assez affolant la
manière dont il y a un vrai travail pour
aller faire de la conviction pour aller
essayer de de convaincre et en
particulier les plus jeunes sur ce sujet
de l'opposition au droit à l'avortement
donc ils sont très actifs ils sont très
organisés ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux en France son pas ultra
minoritaires alors ils sont ultra
minoritaires au sens où 90 % des
Français et des Français sont attachés
au droit à l'avortement donc en France
l'immense majorité quasiment la totalité
des Françaises et des Français sont
attachés au droit à l'avortement mais ça
ne veut pas dire qu' que ça ça peut pas
bouger déjà et puis ça veut pas dire
qu'un jour les personnes qui ne sont qui
sont contre le droit à l'avortement ne
seront pas en position de décider on le
voit là par exemple typiquement 80 % des
Français sont veulent la
constitutionnalisation peut-être que
quelques-uns au Sénat vont faire échouer
la constitutionnalisation donc vous
voyez qu'en fait le sujet c'est pas
tellement est-ce que en France les
Françaises et les Français sont oui ou
non favorables à l'avortement ou ou à la
constitutionnalisation mais bien est-ce
que les personnes qui sont au pouvoir
sont sont aujourd'hui vont faire ce
travail là aux États-Unis même chose la
majorité des Américains sont pour
l'avortement quelquesuns à la Cour
suprême il suffit de quelques-uns bien
placés pour faire tomber tout un tout un
droit on en parlera évidemment on y fera
référence au aux États-Unis mais aussi
en Europe parce que c'est intéressant de
voir ce qui se passe dans certains pays
européens Laureline fauten ça changerait
quoi inscrire l'IVG dans la Constitution
alors c'est c'est une question bien
difficile en réalité parce que euh je je
crois que ça changerait forcément
quelque chose dans la mesure où il
serait impossible pour le législateur de
dire expressément que la femme n'a pas
cette liberté d'avorter donc ça ça
change quelque chose puisque on peut
posé sans en être totalement sûr que le
législateur pourrait le dire aujourd'hui
parce que ça n'est pas inscrit dans la
Constitution mais au-delà de cette
impossibilité qui en résulterait le fait
que la loi ne peut pas dire que la
liberté d'avorter n'existe pas on ne
sait pas bien en fait ce que ça va
garantir parce que le
législateur doit fixer toutes les
conditions dans lesquelles cette liberté
est reconnue à la femme euh combien de
semaines euh est-ce que c'est remboursé
voilà tout un tas de tout un tas de
choses e ça qui en réalité détermine la
nature véritable de cette liberté ou de
ce droit peu importe d'ailleurs comment
on l'appelle on y reviendra peut-être
mais a priori ça change simplement le
fait qu'on ne pourra pas
interdire revenir sur l'idée qu'il que
la femme a la liberté d'avorter SAF à
modifier de nouveau la Constitution sauf
à modifier de nouveau la Constitution
bien sûr parce que j'entend parler
beaucoup de
sanctuarisation on est en train de
vouloir modifier la Constitution
comprendre dans 5 ans on peut vouloir la
modifier encore donc la sanctuarisation
a toujours un un effet temporaire quoi
qu'il arrive qui dépend toujours de ce
qui se passe à un moment donné dans la
classe politique et dans l'espace social
alors il y a aussi une dimension
politique dans la prise de position de
Gérard Larcher on va y revenir avec avec
vous Mathieu comment vous ça ça vous
surprend en quelque sorte cette cette
prise de position oui c'est une sortie
qui qui interroge et qui a raisonn comme
un coup de semonce dans un processus qui
paraissait jusqu'àalors bien huilé hein
depuis le vote l'an dernier on l'a
rappelé de la proposition de loi LFI à
l'Assemblée puis au Sénat dans une
version qui avait été réécrite par
l'ancien président de la commission des
lois Philippe Bas beaucoup
d'observateurs y compris au sommet de
l'État y compris l'Élysée on avait
conclu qu'à condition de trouver les
mots pour le dire euh et bien
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution pouvait rassembler une
majorité des 3/5e euh réunies en en
congrès hein d'ailleurs la date avait
été fixée et puis voilà que le président
du Sénat 3è personnage de l'État revient
non sur la forme mais sur le fond du
dossier avec deux arguments qui
souffrent d'être discutés d'un point de
vue politique alors on prend le premier
d'abord l'IVG n'est pas menacé dans
notre pays dit Gérard rché ce qui est
vrai on l'a dit aucun parti aucune aucun
élu ne réclame de revenir sur la loi
veille mais alors pourquoi s'en privé
pourquoi attendre que le consensus ne
s'effrite pourquoi attendre prendre le
risque que la loi veille soit remise en
cause pour s'y atteler ça ça ne tient
pas la route politiquement gouvern c'est
prévoir disait Émile Gérardin et une
inscription solennelle deivier dans la
Constitution ne changerait rien à l'état
du droit actuel de l'IVG dit le Conseil
d'État n'enlèverait rien à personne et
puis surtout consacrerait l'engagement
de la France et témoignerait de son
attachement au valeurs de la dignité
humaine pourrait-on dire en paraphrasant
qui Jacques Chirac qui lui fit inscrire
l'abolition de la peine de mort dans la
Constitution alors que personne ne la
menaçait donc pour moi ce premier
argument ne tient pas la route donc ça
c'est pour le premier argumentg n'est
pas menacé dans notre pays le second
main le second argument de il interroge
plus encore la cons ition n'est pas un
catalogue de droits sociaux et sociétaux
a poursuivi le président du Sénat on l'a
vu ce qui témoigne quand même d'une
perception toute particulière de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est-ce un droit social ou sociétal qui
deviendrait étaufé un catalogue
d'avancée contemporaine ou bien
s'agit-il d'une liberté fondamentale
alors si pour les juristes la loi veille
en dépénalisant l'IVG avait instauré une
forme de droit et ben pour nombre de
femmes elle a consacré une liberté
liberté à disposer de leur corps liberté
à disposer de leur vente même de leur
utérus certaine mais en tout cas une
liberté non négociable et cette
expression de Gérard Larcher donne le
sentiment qu'on minore la portée de
cette loie fondatrice que fut la loi
veille et je trouve que la droite prend
une nouvelle fois le risque de passer à
côté d'une révolution ou d'une évolution
en tout cas majeure de notre histoire
dont elle a pourtant et c'est là
l'ironie de l'affaire la paternité
puisque la lo veille quand même
remontons à Simone veille c'est sous
jusquà et et là on parle de politique
maintenant comment vous expliquer cette
prise de position ben au-delà des
arguments avancés plusieurs explications
fleurissent la volonté de ne pas se
laisser imposer dictter un calendrier
par
l'exécutif pour ne pas lui faire de
cadeau l'occasion aussi de ressouder la
majorité sénatoriale voire de flatter la
frange la plus conservatrice de la
droite à l'approche des élections
européennes autant d'arguments de petite
politiqu qui viennent instrumentaliser
d'une certaine façon un grand
prininstrip celui de la loiville agnè
caniller petite politique il y a aussi
cette ces
arrièrespensées non je pense pas je
pense que le débat doit dépasser bien
évidemment les enjeux strictement même
si le sénate pas se mettre le couteau
sous la gorge et que quand on a fixé
déjà la date du Congrès avant même que
nous soyons réunis nous ayons voté on
voit bien que c'est metettre un peu de
pression sur le sur le Sénat néanmoins
vous dites c'est vrai que l'enjeu il
dépasse largement C ces enjeux
politiques c'est un truc dans un
catalogue l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse je dis pas que c'est un truc
dans un catalogue je dis que la
Constitution n'est pas faite pour être
une énumération c'est pas comme ça
qu'elle a été conçue initialement par
les pères fondateurs pour être une
énumération de droits de droit sociaux
notamment et et si on commence à ouvrir
la porte on va pouvoir d'autres inscrire
d'autres droits le droit à
reconnaissance à reconnaître le mariage
des personnes de même sexe le droit à
effectivement la GPA j'ai vu que c'était
dans les amendements qui étaient proposé
à l'Assemblée nationale bref on peut
aller très loin dans dans dans
l'évolution de notre Constitution or je
rappelle quand même que la Constitution
c'est la règle fondamentale c'est
l'équilibre aussi de ce texte qui nous
garantit à la fois la la structure et
Sture de notre état et la garantie des
droits de l'homme et des libertés
peut-être votre avis là-dessus Laurine
fontaine euh catalogue de droit liberté
fondamentale on joue pas seulement sur
les mots bon alors d'abord je vais quand
même rappeler que la Constitution c'est
aussi la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyens et c'est aussi le
préambule de la Constitution de 1946 qui
est une énumération précisément d'un
certain nombre de droits sociaux et puis
aussi nous sommes en 2024 et en 2024
aujourd'hui on ne fait pratiquement plus
une constitution sans énoncer un certain
nombre de droits les droits qu'à un
moment donné une société reconnaît quand
on regarde toutes les constitutions qui
ont été faites en Europe de l'Est à la
fin des années 1990 quand on regarde
également les constitutions qui ont été
faites dans le cadre du Printemps arabe
ou toutes les constitutions en Amérique
latine et bien toutes Aujourd'hui
euh procède à une énumération des droits
qui sont considéré à un moment donné
comme fondamentaux pour pour une société
donc ce qui était ce qui valait
peut-être en 1958 peut-être peut être
relativisé aujourd'hui je voudrais quand
même faire une distinction enfin faire
une précision sur droit et liberté oui
justement parce que il n'existe pas de
norme juridique qui fait cette
distinction c'est-à-dire que quand vous
avez un droit ou une liberté qui est
qualifiée comme telle par une norme
juridique ça n'emporte pas en soi une
conséquence par des conséquences
différentes en revanche puisque la
doctrine depuis longtemps a essayé de
faire cette distinction qui aujourd'hui
à mon avis n'est plus tellement valable
hein on a on dit que droit c'est
supérieur à liberté mais quand on
regarde que la liberté d'aller venir et
la liberté d'entreprendre sont mieux
protégés que le droit au logement on
voit bien que la distinction n'a pas de
véritable portée en revanche on voit
qu'il y a une intention derrière ceux
qui utilise ces termes le débat qui a
lieu depuis le début entre le Sénat
l'Assemblée sur droit et liberté et bien
manifeste une certaine intention en
effet où les uns disent il faut
reconnaître un droit comme quelque chose
vraiment de fondamental sur lequel on ne
pourra jamais revenir qui obligerait
l'État qui obligerait l'État à être à
intervenir de manière positive et donc
et ceux qui au contraire disent non non
il faut que ce soit qu'une
liberté qui donc adresse moins
d'obligations à l'état donc il y a cette
intention là mais en droit ça n'emporte
aucune conséquence parce que tout
dépendra de comment le législateur
organise cel d' alors justement pour
pour continuer d'alimenter cette
réflexion regardons en détail ce que
prévoit le le projet de loi
constitutionnel qui est soumis à
l'assemblée depuis ce matin la loi
détermine les conditions dans lesquelles
s'exercice la liberté garantie liberté
garantie à la femme d'avoir recours à
une interruption volontaire de grossesse
liberté garantie plutôt que droit à
l'IVG Cécile mafer est-ce que ces mots
sont suffisant pour vous liberté
garantie puis quel sens vous leur vous
donnez à ces mots alors
idéalement serait pas été à cet
endroit-là déjà ça aurait pas été écrit
de cette manière là mais là où je
rejoins aussi tout à l'heure ce que
disait la la sénatrice Mélanie Vogel
c'est que nous on va aller avec ce qui
fonctionne parce que l'importance c'est
vous êtes pragmatique il faut un texte
qui passe oui et puis aussi ce qu'on
disait c'est-à-dire le les effets vont
pas être révolutionnaires pour les
femmes d'aujourd'hui euh mais elles sont
hautement symboliques et les symboles
ont aussi un impact sur les choses et
ell c'est autement symbolique dans le
contexte international qu'on connaît et
autement symbolique dans le contexte
aussi franco-français qu'on connaît
malgré tout avec des mouvements
anti-avortement qui sont quand même en
train de devenir de plus en plus forts
euh droit liberté je suis assez d'accord
avec vous il y a pas de enfin voilà il y
a pas vous êtes d'ailleurs bien plus
spécialiste que moi il y a pas de de
grande différence moi d'ailleurs j'aime
beaucoup le sujet de la l'idée de la
liberté pour les femmes donc moi ce
mot-là il me va bien ce qui était
difficile pour moi c'est la version
complète de même si on a poussé he tous
les sénateurs et sénatrices à voter
l'amendement de Philippe Bas on le fait
que dire la la de voir entérriner la loi
encadre la liberté vraiment ce qui
prévalait c'était que la loi encadrait
et donc c'est vrai que là le fait qu'on
puisse quand même valoriser le fait que
c'est une liberté qui est garant ti ça
permet de rééquilibrer les choses
c'est-à-dire qu'on est pas uniquement
dans le fait de dire que les
législateurs et législatrices vont fixer
les conditions et donc en fait on
pourrait très bien se dire fixer les
conditions c'est on n pas le droit
d'avorter après une semaine on n pas
d'avorter ou alors il faut écouter les
battements de cœur et cetera là le fait
quand même de dire que c'est une liberté
qui est garantie ça permet d'avoir à mon
sens d'être un peu plus dans un texte
qui va vers ce qu'on souhaitait faire
c'est-à-dire sanctuariser mais même si
on est d'accord absolument que c'est pas
du tout ça qui va dire que pour toujours
et les droits des femmes c'est jamais
pour toujours on le sait bien nous les
féministes donc ça dira pas c'est pour
toujours mais quand même voilà il y a y
a C il y a cet équilibre qui est là et
le fait de dire liberté garantie moi ça
moi liberté garantie ça me va ça me va
très bien euh et voilà et dans l'idéal
c'est vrai qu'on peut tout à fait
réfléchir mais plus tard on le fera plus
tard à une charte de l'égalité femme
homme comme il y a une charte de
l'environnement dans la Constitution h
alors vous avez évoqué la question du
calendrier effectivement euh il y a a
cette critique d'une pression mise par
le gouvernement on écoute Bruno illot le
président du groupe LR sur ce point on
voit bien que le gouvernement en plaçant
par exemple le Congrès début mars
possiblement alors que nous l'examen
l'examen du Sénat sera la fin du mois
février postule qu'il y aurait un
alignement docile du Sénat sur
l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas ça le
travail dès lors qu'il s'agit en plus de
la Constitution le constituant les deux
chambres d' sont à égalité le Sénat est
à égalité en terme de pouvoir de droit
vis-à-vis de l'Assemblée nationale et et
donc c'est suputé qu'il y aurait un avis
conforme mais je pense que il y aura un
débat et pour un certain nombre la
liberté garantie ça veut dire un droit
et ici ça n'est pas du tout le sens de
ce qui avait été discuté il y a quelques
mois alors j'entends bien effectivement
défense du parlementarisme très bien on
est dans une sorte de bras de fer don
parler ma avec le président de la
République qui a évoqué lors de sa
conférence de presse la possibilité pour
Gabriel hatal de se passer du du
Parlement pour faire pour faire aboutir
quelques réformes bref mais l'impression
qu'on a c'est que le enfin la majorité
de droite et du centre du Sénat se
cherche quelques prétexte pour
finalement ne ne pas ne pas voter cette
cette réforme constitutionnelle comme si
l'avancée portée par Philippe B il a
quelques semaine avait un peu surpris
tout le
monde non je pense pas c'est un argument
supplémentaire mais mais il reste quand
même on l'a dit tout à l'heure la
question de fond c'est-à-dire que nous
il n'y a pas dans notre majorité au
Sénat d'une une majorité franche pour
l'inscription dans la Constitution vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure ça va se jouer
à quelques voix quelques voix dans
quelques voix dans l'autre sens oui
d'autant plus que Philippe B avait quand
même pris tout le monde par surprise
parce que c'était eu vous le
reconnaissez d' c'est C de c'est de
l'autorité publique donc là il y a eu
quoi il y a eu un une sorte de retour en
arrière dans les semaines qui on qui ont
suivi ce ce vote non il y a évidemment
une réflexion qui euh qui évolue mais il
y a des personnes mais que ce soit Bruno
retaillot que ce soit Gérard Larché que
ce soit rvé Marseille qui sont fermement
convaincus que c'est pas une bonne idée
de l'inscrire dans la Constitution donc
qui reste ancré dans leur position et
qui défendront leur position après je
vous dis pas que c'est vrai que pour en
discuter pas mal avec mes collègues il y
en a qui évoluent dans leurs idées
souvent sous la pression d'ailleurs
populaire euh qui euh chez eux sentent
la pression et donc ça les ça les fait
évoluer dans leur vote donc c'est pour
ça que je ne sais pas ce qui sera ça ça
pose une question parce que être élu
c'est quand même être représentant donc
c'est pas juste la pression populaire
parce que il y a quand même une très
fort une forme quasi de quasi unanimité
euh euh des Français sur ce sujet est-ce
que vous ne redoutez pas de passer à
côté de l'histoire d'une certaine façon
on a l'impression que la droite sur les
grandes questions sociétales à chaque
fois elle est contre sur le moment elle
fut contre le Pax par exemple batailla
contre le Pax elle fut contre et puis au
final elle ne l'a pas abrogé en disant
on le garde c'est très bien elle fut
contre le mariage pour tous et elle
batailla contre le mariage pour tous
puis au final on entend maintenant des
gens qui ont manifesté comp dire ben non
finalement je regrette j'étais pas pour
est-ce qu'on va pas avoir dans 5 ans
dans 10 ans des des gens qui vont dire
bah oui finalement je regrette une fois
de plus on est passé à côté écoutez je
sais pas parce que être élu c'est aussi
c'est certes représenter ses citoyens
mais c'est aussi défendre ses
convictions donc avant tout on est élu
sur un projet sur des idées et donc on
est aussi là pour défendre ses
convictions donc chacun a des intimes
convictions sur le sujet et à forciorie
quand ce sont des sujets sociétaux et
des sujets humains donc chacun va
défendre ses convictions et ses
positions après chacun est libre aussi
de discuter d'entendre de réfléchir et
d'évoluer d'évoluer dans sa dans sa
réflexion c'est pour ça que je pense que
un certain nombre de nos collègues
auront aussi évolué entre le dernier
vote et les débats qui vont venir je
reprends deux exemples la droite
reviendra pas sur le Pax la droite
reviendra pas sur le mariage pour tous
non mais la dro donc on a l'impression
que vous avez toujours 10 ans de retard
mais écoutez je sais pas si on a 10 ans
de retard on on on défend aussi des
convictions on défend aussi des idées
donc elles s'expriment tel qu'on les
perçoit au moment où on vote après c'est
vrai que la droite évolue les personnes
évoluent aussi avec la société mais
c'est pas forcément que d'être en retard
sur ce temp c'est aussi à un moment
donné d'affirmer ses idées d'affirmer
ses convictions alors on est sur le cas
C Andrier tiens dernière minute en cette
fin d'après-midi euh le garder s éc du
pomoriti à l'Assemblée cet après-midi il
a promis je cite de prendre le temps
qu'il faut pour faire aboutir cette
réforme historique donc voilà déjà une
une petite réponse sur le calendrier
c'est pas ce qui me semble le plus
important en Revan je voudrais que on
ouvre un un un chapitre sur l'hypothèse
d'une menace de d'extrême droite contre
l'avortement en France écoutons euh le
sénateur Europe Écologie les vers
Yannick Jade qui réagissait ce matin
c'était sur notre antenne au propos de
Gérard Larcher les sénatrices et les
sénateurs à être responsablebl de ce
point de vue on voit dans les différents
pays y compris qui sont en train d'être
menacés ou menés par des coalition
d'extrême droite et de droite d'extrême
droite et de droite revenir sur le droit
à l'avortement donc le mettre dans la
Constitution c'est protéger le droit à
l'avortement alors que que encore une
fois regardez dans le monde quand
l'extrême droite et la droite gouverne
ils remettent jamais en cause la
concentration des richesses ils
remettent jamais en cause le libéralisme
ils remettent jamais en cause donc à la
fin qu'est-ce qu'il remettent en cause
ils remettent en cause les droits de la
société alors est-ce possible en France
de voir un nouveau pouvoir populiste
d'extrême droite remettre en cause l'IVG
on va peut-être s'appuyer bonsoir
Jonathan attendu prier sur des exemples
européens parce que effectivement
certains populistes s'engouffre dans la
brèche ouis effectivement et l'Italie
hein particulièrement Thomas Georgia
Meloni qui est thomanet depuis près d'un
an et demi en Italie c'est toujours dit
hostile ouvertement à l'avortement et n'
cessé de vanter les valeurs de la
famille chrétienne entre guillemets he
si publiquement la la présidente du
conseil d'extrême droite elle assure ne
pas vouloir toucher à la loi de 1978 qui
dépénalise l'avortement au niveau local
c'est vraiment une autre paire de manche
les régions qui sont gouvernées par la
coalition de droite dont tes membres
sont partis fratellit d'Italia et bien
multiplie les obstacles à l'avortement
il y a par exemple des réductions de de
financement des plannings familiaux des
associations provies qui ont par exemple
été autorisées à installer des bureaux
dans certains hôpitaux dans certaines
régions le Piémont les abruses il y a
même une allocation qui est octroyée à
des femmes qui renonceraient à l'IVG le
tout au service de son obsession de la
natalité là encore entre guillemets ce
qu'elle rappelait ce sommet ultra
conservateur organisé par Victor Orban
en Hongrie c'était en sept dernier
écoutez
là nous voulons défendre la natalité la
revitaliser en affirmant que la famille
ne limite la liberté de personne mais
qu'elle augmente la richesse de chacun
nous ne croyons pas que l'État puisse
remplacer la famille et lorsque cela a
été tenté dans le passé comme ce fut le
cas en Europe de l'Est sous le régime
soviétique les résultats ont servi
d'avertissement pour que tout le monde
ne répète pas cette
expérience
et jordia Meloni elle est plus sournoise
même sur l'IVG c'est qu'elle ne revient
même pas elle ne veut même pas en fait
créer de nouvelles lois plus restrictive
c'est qu'en fait elle laisse la loi
actuelle en l'état parce que elle permet
déjà au médecins de ne pas appliquer
l'avortement au N au nom d'une clause de
conscience et selon les derniers
chiffres disponibles c'est environ 7
médecins sur 10 qui refusent déjà de le
pratiquer remise en cause de de
l'interruption volontaire de de
grossesse qui existe aussi dans d'autres
pays européens oui absolument Thomas et
on l'évoquait on l'effleurait la grande
alliée de l'Italie sur le sujet c'est la
Hongrie où il y a un décret qui est
entré en vigueur en 2022 et qui
contraint les femmes qui désirent
avorter à écouter les battements de de
cœur du fettus en Slovaquie pas moins de
11 propositions de loi en 2 ans pour
tenter de restreindre l'accès à
l'avortement émanant d'un puissant lobby
catholique intégriste plus difficile
encore l'exemple polonel où l'avortement
n'est autorisé qu'en cas de viol ou de
danger pour la vie de la mer depuis
janvier 2021 et après avoir tenté de
l'interdire totalement en 2016 le
gouvernement l'a restreint en supprimant
la possibilité d'avorter en cas de
malformation grave du fitus et en fait
ça c'était 90 % des des cas d'avortement
en Pologne et vous le disiez en
préambule l'IVG est donc bien fragile
même dans l'UE et c'est pour ça qu'en
France et ben les défenseurs de ce droit
vous en parliez au tout début de
l'émission veulent à tout prix
l'inscrire dans la Constitution et c'est
aussi pour le signal que ça pourrait
envoyer à l'Europe écouter Mélanie Vogel
à ce sujet ce serait un signal
formidable un signal d'espoir qui montre
que en fait aujourd'hui on peut aussi
progresser sur ces droitsl il y a pas
que des reculs il y a aussi des progrès
et ça donnerit une énergie et une force
à beaucoup de mouvements féministes qui
sont dans des situations aujourd'hui
moins protectrices que la France sur le
droit l'vg et qui vont avoir un élan
pour pouvoir aller plus loin donc ça
fait effectivement partie de ce qui
m'anime pour mener ce combat ça
dépassent largement nos frontières à la
fois les mouvements réactionnaires
dépassent nos frontières mais les
mouvements progressistes féministes qui
peuvent arriver à des victoires pour les
droits fondamentaux aussi donc voilà
Thomas vous l'avez bien compris en tout
cas l'IVG recule globalement dans
l'Union européenne seul peut-être lueur
d'espoir si on peut dire c'est que pour
la première fois en juin dernier le
Parlement Maltais a adopté à l'unanimité
un texte qui autorise l'avortement alors
qu'avant il était tout simplement
illégal mais c'est une avancée en en
demi-teinte vous en doutez parce que
l'accès à l'IVG reste encore très
restreint dans ce pays merci Jonathan
pour pour toutes ces explications Anne
Cécile je reviens vers vous parce que en
France vous nous avez dit qu'il y avait
des des des antivg très actifs notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux les médias
sociaux à destination des des jeunes
mais est-ce qu'il y a une expression
politique de ça quel parti porte ce ce
projet il y en a-t-il un seulement alors
ça alors
peut-être peut-être plutôt dans la
mouvance autour d'éc Zemmour ça c'est
certain c'est-à-dire que quand on voit
là le travail qu'on a fait d'étudier sur
les réseaux sociaux quels étaient les
comptes qui émettaient des fausses
informations pour aller induire en
erreur un certain nombre de de personnes
et en particulier les jeunes on est
remonté beaucoup à des personnes qui
sont très actifes dans la sphère DESC
Zemour donc autour de lui ça c'est sûr
on est dans cette mouvance là mais aussi
autour plus généralement autour du du
parti d'extrême droite du du
rassemblement national on a aussi on a
aussi ces mouvances là mais comme tout à
l'heure on on le disait il y a des
personnes à droite qui ont euh la droite
plus classique euh on a des des
personnes qui ont des convictions prof
fond de conviction intimes et les
convictions intimes c'est pas est-ce que
c'est plus ou moins la bonne virgule
dans la Constitution la la la conviction
intime sur l'avortement c'est en vrai je
ne suis pas d'accord avec le droit à
l'avortement et c'est pour ça que je ne
veux pas le mettre dans la Constitution
donc en fait on a en France des
personnes qui sont à droite
classiquement qui sont qui ont des
convictions intimes contre l'avortement
mais qu'ils ne le disent pas parce
qu'ils savent bien que c'est pas
possible de l'assumer complètement mais
qui vont dire je le veux pas dans la
Constitution mais en vrai ce qu'ils
aiment pas trop c'est le droit à
l'avortement en général et puis on a
plutôt à l'extrême droite parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le droit à
l'avortement euh fait partie euh
vraiment des des des des des obsessions
euh de l'extrême droite dans tous les
pays du monde aujourd'hui une extrême
droite populiste nationaliste qui va
dire leur leur pourquoi parce qu'en fait
ils vont dire euh l'affaiblissement de
la société en particulier euh européenne
l'affaiblissement des sociétés
occidentales c'est à cause d'une
féminisation une dévirilisation de
l'occid cident qui est à cause des
féministes du coup ce qui se passe c'est
qu'il y a moins de de de virilité moins
de masculinité il y a un affaiblissement
du modèle familial il y a un grand
remplacement par des populations qui
viennent du sud parce que à cause des
féministes les femmes en particulier en
France les femmes françaises les femmes
entre guillemets de souche avortent
prennent la contraception font moins
d'enfants et donc on arrive à un
affaiblissement des familles de souche
occidental versus d'autres familles donc
déjà ça c'est des théories qui sont
fausses d'accord on avorte autant
aujourdhui qu'avant il y a pas de de
sujet là-dessus et surtout c'est
extrêmement raciste et vraiment ils ont
dans le viseur c'est c'est c'est
vraiment un truc c'est leur logiciel ils
ont dans le viseur le droit à
l'avortement donc il faut pas il faut
regarder un peu lire un peu ce qu'ils
disent écouter et quand on regarde là
GEG Meloni elle a participé à un grand
congrès sur la natalité et qu'est-ce
qu'elle dit elleelle elle elle va dire
des choses sur le droit à l'avortement
c'est que natalité droit à l'avortement
tout ça c'est des discours qui sont
extrêmement extrêmement liés extrêmement
liés à toute cette mouvance d'extrême
droite juste pourir ERC Zemour il disait
pendant sa campagne présidentielle qu'il
ne reviendrait pas sur l'IVG mais il
disait parce qu'il avait aussi ses
ambiguités que l'interruption volontaire
de grossess devait être une exception
dans des circonstances exceptionnelles
ça il l'ait dit en et par exemple ils
vont dire on le Rint que pour les cas de
viol quand on sait qu'en plus il faut 7
ans pour juger si un viol est un viol on
a le temps d'en avoir plusieurs
effectivement on a cité les exemples
européens on va aussi faire un focus sur
les États-Unis évidemment le droit àivg
il a reculé vous le savez décision de la
Cour suprême du 24 juin 2022 notamment à
cause pas seulement mais notamment à
cause des juges conservateur nommé par
Donald Trump il y a CIN juges qui
avaient voté en faveur de cette décision
sur les C il y en a trois qui ont été
nommés par par Trump et celui qui est de
nouveau candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il s'en orgueillit de ce
résultat
écoutez pendant 54 ans ils ont essayé de
faire annuler l'arrêt RAW versus Red et
je l'ai fait et je suis fier de l'avoir
fait il ne fait aucun doute que personne
d'autre que moi n'y serait parvenu
Laurine fontaine on vous avez écrit un
livre sur le fonctionnement du Conseil
constitutionnel en France les les deux
institutions sont pas totalement
comparables la Cour suprême d'un côté le
Conseil constitutionnel de de de l'autre
est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer un
conseil constitutionnel qui se
conservatise vous voyez ce que je veux
dire au point de remettre en cause des
droits fondamentaux comme
l'avortement
euh moi je pense qu'on peut l'imaginer
oui sans que ce soit une certitude ou à
court terme ou à moyen terme j'en ai
aucune idée mais je pense qu'on peut
l'imaginer euh on a bien une loi qui
vient d'être adopté et qui justement va
faire l'objet d'une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel demain euh dont dont le
contenu euh est est quand même très très
à droite euh et et ça je pense qu'on ne
l'aurait pas forcément dit il y a deux
ou 3 ans euh à partir du moment où les
personnalités qui euh sont membres du
Conseil constitutionnel sont nommés par
des personnalités politiques le
président de la République le Pr
président du Sénat le président de
l'Assemblée nationale euh il faut
comprendre que la composition du conseil
pour le moment va dépendre de qui siège
euh dans ces différentes dans ces
différent donc il font forcément de la
politique c'est ce que vous nous dites
ils font pas seulement du droit et les
sages du Conseil constitutionnel c'est
que on peut faire du droit tout en étant
politisé hein ça je crois que c'est pas
du tout un problème euh on peut faire
dire beaucoup de choses à la
constitution la preuve la Cour suprême
disait pendant plusieurs décennies qu'il
n'était pas inconstitutionnel euh
d'autoriser l'avortement et elle dit
maintenant que il n'est pas
inconstitutionnel de l'interdire donc
c'est une sur une simple base
d'interprétation de de la Constitution
et qui interprète ce sont des
personnalités qui certes sont des
juristes mais qui ont des opinions
politiques et qui ont été nommés pour
des raisons politiques donc vous nous
dites ils ne sont pas impartiaux les les
juges du Conseil constitutionnel
aujourd'hui en France il ne juge pas
dans les conditions de l'impartialité ça
c'est certain euh dans la mesure où ils
ont très souvent un rapport avec les
personnes qui ont adopté la loi ou
eux-même sont intervenus parfois dans le
processus lorsqu'ils n'était pas au
Conseil constitutionnel donc non il ne
juge pas actuellement dans les
conditions de l'impartialité mais
peut-être pas seulement parce qu'ils ne
sont pas juristes s'il l'était ce serait
sans doute un peu différent mais on peut
présumer que ça ne serait pas
fondamentalement différent c'est-à-dire
que à partir du moment où les
nominations dans une cour
constitutionnelle reste exclusivement
politique et qu'il n'y a pas aussi de on
va dire de mise en concurrence ou de
mise on va dire en en discussion de la
nomination comme ça se fait dans
d'autres cours à l'étranger et bien il y
a plus de Chan que ce soit que ce soit
politique pas je j'entends on est un peu
dans une dans une politique fiction ou
dans une juridique fiction quand même
disons-le AG est-ce que parce que
j'entends l'argument consiste à dire pas
de
constitutionnalisation derrière ça le
Conseil constitutionnel est suffisamment
fort pour garantir le droit à
l'avortement c'est ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui oui tout à fait euh le le
Conseil constitutionnel alors d'abord la
référence par rapport au système
étranger on n'est pas du tout dans les
mêmes conditions on peut pas transposer
ce qui se passe aux États-Unis ce qui se
passe en Italie par rapport à ce qui se
passe dans notre État français dans
lequel vous l'avez dit aucun parti
politique aujourd'hui ne remet en
question l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse et je redis gérardch l' dit
nous sommes très attachés à cette
liberté à ce droit fondamental qui est
le le droit à l'IVG en ce qui concerne
effectivement l'inscription enfin le
Conseil constitutionnel le Conseil
constitutionnel a toujours renforcé la
garantie des droits il se prononcé
quatre fois sur les questions
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse
par quatre fois il a renforcé ce ce
droit à l'IVG donc aujourd'hui toute
façon si on a un renversement politique
qui remet en question le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
comme vous l'avez dit on peut remettre
en question la constitution aussi une
constitution elle se modifie elle a déjà
été modifiée 24 fois fois de plus allez
un mot rapide parce que je voudrais
qu'on qu'on parle des conditions d'accès
à l'IBG en en dernier chapitre oui je
voudrais simplement dire que le Conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas renforcé le
droit à l'IVG il a à chaque fois
constaté que ça n'était pas contraire à
la Constitution que de poser des
conditions qui étaient plus plus larges
que qu'auparavant et je voulais juste
oui mais ça aboutissait à un
renforcement quand même des des droits
on peut le dire ça aboutit à dire que la
loi est conforme à la Constitution ça
n'est pas tout à fait la ou
effectivement alors l'accès à
l'interruption Voltaire de grossesse
aujourd'hui quelques chiffres euh en
2022 200 un peu plus de 234000 femmes y
ont eu recours mais c'est de plus en
plus difficile dans notre pays de
trouver un centre IVG 130 de ces centres
ont fermé en 15 ans an CC mafer est-ce
que c'est pas ça l'urgence alors c'est
aussi une urgence mais en fait on peut
faire deux choses à la FO on peut faire
les deux c'est ça qui est pratique du
coup mais oui sur l'accès à l'IVG il
faut effectivement garantir l'accès à
l'IVG ça c'est très important et ça
faisait partie d'ailleurs des textes qui
avaient été proposés au tout début par
par un parlementaire mais garantir
l'accès à iivg ça va ça veut dire
permettre de faire en sorte que pour une
femme elle puisse avoir rapidement un
rendez-vous pas très loin de chez elle
avec un professionnel bien formé qui est
outillé qui a tout ce qu'il faut qui a
les bonnes molécules ou les bons
instruments pour pouvoir pratiquer ça
veut dire aussi dans une société dans
laquelle la avortement n'est pas une
honte euh ça veut dire aussi travailler
ça travailler le le fait que bah 40 %
des femmes avortent dans notre pays
c'est un droit extrêmement utilisé
extrêmement utile pour beaucoup de
femmes et pour des hommes aussi mais
alors comment vous expliquez cette
fermeture 130 centres fermés en en 15
ans c'est quoi c'est
finalement le le le la la grande misère
de notre système de santé qui frappe
aussi les les centres IVG ou alors c'est
c'est autre chose alors les c'est 135
fermeture c'est souvent des fermetures
de maternité parce qu'en fait ce qu'on
sait moins c'est que la plupart des
maternités ont des centres de
d'avortement au sein des des maternités
donc quand on ferme une maternité de
proximité pour faire une méga une méga
méga maternité et bien en fait ça va
être des centres IVG aussi qu'on va
fermer sur le territoire donc c'est ça
les les 130 centres d'IVG qui ont été
fermés ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
dans beaucoup
d'hôpitaau l'activité d'orthogénie
l'activité d'IVG est en fait une
activité qui est comme elle est très mal
remboursée par la Sécurité sociale elle
est pas du tout rentable du coup les
cliniques privées ne vont pas du tout
sur ces sujets-là et les hôpitau public
euh et bien euh dans euh voilà dans la
manière dont ils fonctionnent et dont
ils vont être amenés de plus en plus à
fonctionner à l'avenir comme c'est pas
des services qui sont très rentables et
ben c'est pas des services qui sont très
favorisés qui sont pas très attractifs
pour le personnel et qui sont souvent
euh voilà un peu délaissé donc c'est
vrai que après ce sont les femmes qui en
payent les conséquences alors on a un
petit peu ouvert les missions qui que
les sages-femmes peuvent accomplir pour
pouvoir accompagner les femmes aussi
dans leur dans leur souhait de terminer
une grossesse donc heureusement
maintenant de plus en plus de
sages-femmes peuvent prescrire le les
les les pilules avortives et accompagner
les femmes d'ailleurs des je crois des
médecins généralistes également peuvent
le faire et ça permet de de compenser un
petit peu mais on est voilà on n'est pas
forcément dans une offre qui est celle
que préféraent toutes les femmes agès
can est-ce que pour pour
compenser le risque de passer pour voilà
une une majorité de droite et du centre
au Sénat en retard sur l'histoire est-ce
que vous portez c'est cet enjeu voilà de
de de d'offrir aux femmes de vrais
moyens pour accéder à l'IVG tout à fait
je rejoins totalement ce que ce qui
vient d'être dit sur la nécessité et on
l'a toujours dit à chaque fois dans not
débats au Sénat on a toujours porté
l'idée que il fallait renforcer c'est
l'accès à l'IVG et ça passe par quoi ça
passe par des moyens supplémentaires ça
passe par une prévention aussi
supplémentaire une information des
jeunes filles des jeunes hommes aussi de
de la manière dont on peut avoir recours
et des lieux où on peut avoir accès à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ça impose aussi d'augmenter le
remboursement des actes de recours à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
de renforcer les moyens et puis de
lutter contre la désertification
d'une manière générale d'une manière
générale mais est-ce que c'est un axe
que vous allez porter oui c'est un axe
que nous portons au Sénat avec la
commission des affaires sociales avec
Philippe Mouillet son président nous le
portons à chaque PLFSS parce que nous
pensons vraiment que l'enjeu ce n'est
pas la Constitution qui donnera les
moyens c'est du domaine réglementaire
c'est du domaine législatif et financier
et c'est là-dessus que nous devons nous
battre mais on peut faire les deux en
même temps oui mais il y a une priorité
sur l'autre bon d'accord on a bien
compris quelle était votre priorité
constition ça coûte pas cher
ah bah réunir le congrès à versaill ça
coûte cher oui mais moins quand même
bref dernière question Laureline
fontaine sur peut-être sur l'accès à ces
centres il y a quoi il y a il y a une
une inégalité devant la loi de fait
aujourd'hui en France en fonction des
départements des euh des villes où l'on
où l'on réside
ben c'est c'est c'est certain mais comme
il y a une inégalité pardon euh de
beaucoup devant différents services
publics hein l'IVG n'échappe pas à la
règle pour le coup et c'est bien dommage
euh mais
je voudrais juste peut-être dire que
Gérard lcher a peut-être manqué une
occasion en étant si laconique sur cette
questionl de de de dire ce qu'on attend
d'une constitution parce que finalement
en disant simplement ça n'est pas un
catalogue de droits sociaux et sociétaux
euh il passe un peu vite sur finalement
qu'est-ce que c'est le rôle d'une
constitution et ça serait à mon avis un
bon débat puisque'en effet la majeure
partie des Français sont favorables à la
constitutionnalisation de l'avortement
euh et donc il faudrait pour que que on
puisse légitimement j'allais dire pour
que la représentation puisse
légitimement s'opposer à cette
constitutionnalisation avoir un débat
beaucoup plus important sur ce que c'est
une constitution et sur ce qu'on met
dans une constitution et et je crois que
il y aurait vraiment un un débat
d'avenir h merci beaucoup merci à tout
d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat j'ai
rappelé Laureline fontaine le titre de
votre livre la Constitution maltraitée
anatomie du Conseil constitutionnel s
publié aux éditions Amsterdam à bientôt
sur sur Public Sénat